jumping in um because i got a lot of
questions what what do you wish more
people knew about being an editor
you know we kind of quite like living in
the shadows so maybe i won't tell you an
answer to that
i think you know it's the um
it's the art that hides itself i mean i
hope
that people realize that we don't just
take the board off the front i mean i
think there's this illusion that you
know
the command action and the command cut
is is a direction actually to the editor
um
no uh i think they
i hope that they'd realize that we're at
the sort of still point in the turning
world of all of the
elements that make up a good film and
that's performance and
story and
pacing and music and sound effects and
some element of control over the visual
so um
yeah i mean you know i think
back in the day there were never things
like collider so when i was starting in
the business um
i genuinely knew absolutely nothing
about it
so i think nowadays people probably hear
too much i don't know if that's
necessarily true but you know anyway um
you've worked on a number of films which
one do you think changed the most from
when you started editing to what people
actually saw
i mean arrival i would say
i mean there was some great deal of
freedom in that movie it's funny i think
dune of as as a kind of continuation in
some ways of arrival insofar as you know
we have to kind of create a very
um compelling
inner world for amy adams character in
the rival but also for paul atreides for
timothy charlemagne's character in june
you know it has to be
it can't just be decoration it has to be
this essential thing where he feels
you know an innocent caught up in a a
dreadful purpose
and
you know that was one of the things that
we spent most time
um working on it's funny you know the
one would think from the kind of these
amazing um set pieces in the film that
they would have taken the most time
editorially that actually no i think the
things that really take the time in a
film like due now that are the intimate
moments you know like uh there's a scene
in a tent between
paula tradies and his mother it's a very
high charge
you know high-energy scene and
that we spent a long time working on
just getting it right whereas the fight
scene at the end i think stayed almost
frame accurately the same
as two days after they shot it it was
just uh
just those that stuff came easily it was
just very well shot and done put it
together very easily uh i have so many
questions about dune because uh it's
amazing and i i have so many questions
but i have a few others before we get to
it um what technology and programs do
you use
uh to edit
um the main thing is the standard piece
of kit which is avid media composer it's
the one i've been using
for the last 15 years i started on film
and then moved through light works and
three machine beta suites and ended up
in um
ended up in avid and it just seems to be
rock solid so i'm staying with that the
other kind of things that we used during
the pandemic in particular were evercast
which was a way of
uh delhi could stay in montreal i was in
los angeles and i mean you know i have
to say that i've been sitting to the
left of denny for
nearly seven years now i think and
so the right hand side of his face is
actually like the dark side of the moon
to me
um
so being
presented with his face looking directly
at me
on a piece of software evercast was was
quite troubling but um seriously the
other piece of i use a thing called meta
synth i use that a lot it's a kind of
audio piece of software it's not easy to
use but you can download it free and it
just turns things into dreamscapes which
was really useful when we're
building poorer tradies
in a voice uh what do you wish
uh and what do you wish editing software
was better at uh doing
i always wish it was more like minority
report that you could pick things up and
move things by hand i miss the
physicality
and a serious answer is i i used to love
being in film where things were very
physically you'd sit at a at a bench
or you you know and you were carrying
tins and opening tins and putting things
and spooling them out and i kind of want
to work like that i find you know being
a keyboard and mouse
it's just uh i've been doing it a long
time and it started to kind of you know
give me aches and pains how does it work
in terms of
where is the footage stored when you're
editing i'm assuming that um that you
are essentially sandboxing whatever
you're working on so it's you know
possibly
protected from i guess hackers or
whatever but how is it all stored
and how does it work with like backups
and everything god forbid you have a
system failure
well i mean there's a kind of you know
avid works on a system called nexus
which is a kind of giant massive
computer with
i can't remember what we had on doom but
it would have been
50 terabytes or so and it and i'm cabled
between the nexus as is my assistant
who'd have been in a room upstairs
with his english sheepdog and uh we
um that is yes massively protected and
of course it's gone now uh and we had to
kind of put security cameras everywhere
and you know
if my daughter came in late then there
was a whole kind of gun turret that was
pointed after
no it was just you know password
protected highly encrypted
um
but yes we have we had to kind of
disperse at some point during during the
pandemic uh rather than having one
mainframe that kind of ran all of our
cutting rooms my category my assistant's
cutting room second assistance cutting
room vfx
editor's uh cutting room his assistant
sound
all of these people would have been on
one one mainframe but now we were spread
out and working in different sort of you
know spare bedrooms and granny flats and
and and garden sheds around the los
angeles area um
what is actually if you could just take
me through this see let's use dune as an
example so you're starting up first day
of work on dune take me through what
actually happens in terms of how does it
actually get started i mean what's that
process
nowadays i actually start before the
shoot so i'd probably be i was in
budapest on june a couple of weeks
before and that's partly to set up the
equipment and cutting rooms but also
because
the storyboards would have been some of
them some of the kind of you know set
pieces will have been turned into
previews
so i would have been working with
animations but they don't really have
time as a factor they don't really
work out how long to stay on the shot
and especially when there's dialogue in
the scene so
the first couple of days on on in
budapest i was cutting
um a scene where an autofilter trip goes
out to the desert and they rescue a uh
um harvester a spice harvester that's
under worm attack
so you know you have to kind of i was
trying to build in temporary voices
using kind of ai robot
online voices um which is a bit silly
sound effects
just anything to kind of get an idea of
how long to hold things you know a shot
of a dune that you know
a worm is going to burst out of how long
do you hold it before the worm comes out
that was the kind of thing i was working
out there
and i'd be playing that to denny and
we spent a couple of weekends looking at
that stuff making it shorter actually
and uh
changing the order a little bit so that
when people actually went to shoot it
they only shot what they needed and they
knew exactly what they needed so you
know which is important for an aerial
unit that's shooting the dunes are going
to go into the plates at the end of it
but that's that was that's kind of pre
first day first day they shoot on a
monday on tuesday i'm cutting it
together and it just means if there's
any problem i can ring denny or show him
something or go around to set the laptop
um but that really happened actually
kind of avoided going on set a little
bit i'm a tiny bit phobic about that
but um i was around and about so that i
could be in the middle of the door um
what do you do when you have two takes
you love both of them
uh
how do you actually pick the one that's
gonna be the one you use
oh boy well i mean that's a tough one
i mean it's never throwing a coin let's
put it that way it's it's it's
it could be weeks and weeks and weeks of
discussion
i mean that's the thing i mean i feel
like i have to see everything that they
shoot because the temperature of a
performance can vary in small degrees
but it makes a big impact
um i mean
one of the joys a small joy in cutting
dune is is stephen mckinley henderson
who in any sequence that he he features
you could play the entire scene on him
even if he doesn't have a line of
dialogue just because his face is the
most wonderful
subtle mirror of the entire flow of a
scene
so uh you know sometimes i would would
debate not necessarily a different
performance but just one eyebrow lift
for on another
um how long this had to have been the
longest edit maybe how long did this
actually take from
you starting to actual final day
well you have to take into account the
pandemic sort of put a pause into it so
we started i think in march of whatever
the year was before the last one
and then uh then we delivered a kind of
director's cut around christmas
20 it would have been 20 20 and then 20
no 2019 oh my goodness i'm so lost
and then uh then we took a break and
then we were going to go back and do the
last things and start the music and
finish the vfx but the pandemic hit we
went on pause i mean actually me and
daddy carried on working and
although i don't want to
talk glibly about the pandemic because
it sort of you know hurt a lot of people
but for us
and for me particularly it was
it was a real boon because it gave us a
bit of time
and there is a big advantage from
working at home you know if i'm worried
about something at two in the morning
what do i do do i
lie in bed fretting or do i actually
come down and do something useful and
that was really lovely we we really got
into a great rhythm during that period
but then we got back together again in
july i believe and had the thing
finished by um you know it's due to be
released if you remember last christmas
so we were sort of on on board for that
what actually happens with all the
footage
from when you're editing say there's a
few deleted scenes you're like these are
awesome i might never see these again do
you get to keep a copy of these or is it
sort of like really frowned on
jenny is um
you know it's like danny
doesn't really believe in deleted scenes
or anything for kind of a you know
extras or anything like that i mean the
film is the film i think there's we have
a small there was talk about doing a
director's cut of sigari which the only
difference being that there was my
assistant had said the words in
chihuahua
with a rather kind of um funny voice
because we were changing the line of one
of the detainees
and we were changing the line and he he
bravely gave us a recording on her
iphone and it was always i could always
tell where denny was in a in a in an
audience because we used to chuckle
every time we heard it and then when it
came to do the final dub we never used
the voice we used to crowd extra like
you would normally do and i think with
some regret
because
that team always goes past and i'm
always slightly disappointed that it
isn't happy
assistant's voice um
so no in all seriousness there's no
once something's cut you know it's cut
and there's good reason it's
we've
we discarded in all of these four films
i've cut with him we've discarded
really good material but this is what i
mean though look what what i'm saying is
you there might be some great stuff with
harrison ford and blade runner you're
like i love that scene do you keep a
copy or do you not like is that's what i
mean like do you per like
i do i discard it i mean it goes back
into i presume it goes on to warner
brothers shelf
and um there it remains uh with all my
first assemblies and all that kind of
stuff but you know i mean i think this
is a kind of
you know we're all concentrating on the
the rubble on the floor we're not
concentrating on the sculpture that
we've made and that's the thing that
we're mostly proud of and
that's the stuff that kind of gets us up
in the morning it's you know you have to
kind of say goodbye you have to kill
darlings and it's sometimes terribly
painful
but
um it does i don't think it benefits
anybody normally it doesn't reflect well
on people you know it's there's a reason
why things aren't in there uh even if
it's great material it might not fit and
who wants to discuss something that
didn't fit well i think some i i i
totally agree with you but i also think
sometimes um
you know the studios don't want to
release like a three-hour movie and
sometimes you know the studio says you
need to make a movie that maximum is
going to be two hours and 30 minutes
regardless of what you have denis is
obviously in a different level now where
you know then he was earlier in his
career but you know
when you're releasing something
theatrically i think sometimes there's a
running time issue where even if the 30
minutes of footage is amazing
we're not going to release a three-hour
movie you know whatever you know what i
mean
all i can say is there was no pressure
on us at all to deliver any particular
duration on this film
and
i think really important is that
duration is it's kind of meaningless
i mean you know you can have something
that's swift but it's if it's not
engaging if it isn't compelling
it's it can feel like forever
uh whereas you know whereas you can have
something i mean i think the great thing
about june is that you know it's
as an editor you're trying to balance
find a rhythm between the kind of epic
scale of the film and the epic scale of
the universe that frank herbert invented
and that demi has lovingly brought to
life
and
the intimate and if you don't make it
all compelling then what does it matter
if it was an hour and a half it could
could have been really boring
it could be three hours long and be
absolutely riveting it's it's it's pace
is not
really about just about duration it's
about how urgent and how tense the
situation is 100
what did you learn from working with
denis on
arrival and blade runner in sicario that
you took with you into dune
knowing like because you now obviously
have a shorthand you know what he's
looking for you know after working with
him a few times i'm sure it's a lot
different
it's i mean i just learned to trust him
even more i mean i think it was pretty
strong straight away on zacario but you
know on arrival i think there were
sometimes we would agree to do something
that
on first apparition might not be you
know a solid idea there were probably
reasons for not doing it but i kind of
go
to hell with it let's try it what harm
is there and trying and you would find
something
so we sort of often preface our kind of
changes by saying you know bad idea
let's dumb and then from that you know
you end up with some really good stuff
um
i think on uh
on on june you know each of these films
has incrementally
increase the scale of what we're doing
and in terms of the effects you know my
hat's off to him for the you know to be
able to kind of hold on to an idea for
as long as he has
you know i think arguably from his
teenage years a vision of the film it
really you know it's a it's it's it's a
matter of bravery so my admiration goes
from film to the um i am always curious
about the assembly cut first cut versus
the finished film so when you put all
the footage together or let me look did
you have like what was your assembly cut
was it crazy long or was it just long
i don't remember you know on set i can't
remember you know steve it's like two
years ago more or less
um
it would have been longer of course and
there would have been you know
differences in order and
sometimes you know for example there's a
scene that
you know where we intercut the the
discovery of a ring you know that you
call ring
uh with the the death of the father
there's kind of intercut in there which
you know what wouldn't have been the
plan originally
um you know the death of uh later i'm
going into major spoiler territory
unfortunately yeah but um
you know i would say that there's
always
things are longer or they need more work
but you know the inner world of paul
wasn't there at all in the first cup it
was something we knew we were going to
do and denny supplied material for it
but it was very uncertain exactly what
we do and we just said look we'll we'll
figure it out almost like a documentary
it was very much like that on arrival we
had all that material on arrival that
was shot on the lakeside it was
beautiful material but it was a little
uncertain
where it would go and how it would be
shaped and how you would fit it in it's
always you know it it isn't uh you know
like building an ikea cupboard it's a
little bit more hopefully a little bit
more fun than that what was the last
thing you you might not remember this
what was the last thing you cut out of
the film before you picture locked and
why
i don't remember if it involved cutting
it out but the very last change i made
was um one of these visions of paul's
and it was that was a really interesting
sort of thing we found in the edit which
was
trying to kind of you know in the
gomjava scene which is more or less at
the beginning of the films a couple of
scenes in the beginning of the film it
begins the book by the way um that
danny was always searching for something
that
expressed the idea that
the quiz that's had a wreck this kind of
mythical character is born inside his
mind under pressure and
we're kind of trying to figure out how
to do that and actually one of the kind
of big ingredients of it was this tiny
fragment of singing that um an amazing
thing called lua cutler
uh had recorded for hands she recorded
it in a in a
wardrobe somewhere in new york
and deep in the track it wasn't
specifically for that scene we heard it
it's heavily featured in the trailer so
you probably recognize what i'm talking
about and we we put it on that scene and
it suddenly went okay something's awoken
something really quite dark
and um
so right at the end of the film i
remember about a week before we were
meant to drop out our pencils and it was
all like we literally can't do any more
changes stop now
i remember saying to jenny you know we
need to develop that a little bit more
because we set it up and we don't quite
pay it off so i remember just doing in
the last couple of days a lot of work
and a lot of late nights just getting
that
that little uh sequence going just at
the climax of the live fight uh for fan
listen i could have watched like a four
hour version of this movie um i mean i
love this movie so much i am i know fans
are going to want to know did you so
were there a lot of deleted scenes can
you can you actually
you know was it like
i mean i guess were there a lot of
deleted scenes
oh steve
[Laughter]
you know you're drawing me towards a
dangerous territory so i i'll decline to
answer that got it um did you one of the
things that i'm always listen obviously
denise wants to make a part two and
possibly a part three was there anything
that you guys had
shot you're in the edit and you realize
this might be perfect if we get to make
part two
let's save it for that
well you know there was there is some
material that you know maybe was
intended for part one which we thought
we we should defer to part two it will
be
in a different context and you know
nothing from part two was shot
for um this particular film if you can
imagine that would be
four or five months worth of work so
it's not like we shot
four or five months worth of material
and i i neglected
but
maybe maybe there was a scene or
something that you're like well this
this would be perfect for part two and
it doesn't you know let's save it
i think you know what's really
interesting about frank herbert's book
is that some characters do come back but
not necessarily in the same form that
they took originally i mean
those who know the book know that uh
duncan idaho for example reappears so
it's never over until
you know the large lady sings um
which i'll ask you this question maybe
you'll answer this which character
of the in dune
uh ended up losing the most scenes
with i'm not gonna get it steve i'm not
gonna get it i'm not gonna care but
it's it's i you know you know
i would just i will i will not be doing
june 2.
yeah i got it listen this is this is my
job as a reporter i got a dig
i love it i love you for it
i i love your tenacity but i think three
times an hour okay
say no more how did you guys figure out
the way you wanted paul's visions to
actually look
on you know what i mean like i imagine
that's a debate figuring out how do we
want this to be portrayed on screen
you know one of the kind of really key
um discoveries was that there's a
particular kind of camera and i'm not
that clever about camera equipment that
they but it's a particular camera they
use when they were shooting um
a dream vision of james and paul
fighting which is something that is
intended for a little moment late in the
film where paul sees his possible death
at the hands of somebody he thought was
a friend
and
um when they shot it denny noticed this
strange kind of fringing
of the light and it sort of moves like
this and he got really
turned on by it and he ended up asking
them to film like loads and loads of
plates of this of this the rays of light
and i ended up with all this material so
that we could weave interweave it into
the it's part of the fabric of the look
and it was a way if you notice if you
look a second time you'll see that
you know i get it's
it's a really great device from going
from one shot not jump cutting to it the
next shot but having something that sort
of changes the focus and it makes it
feel very much more dreamlike and
you know the thing that it's reminiscent
of
which is a strange thing to say but it's
maybe appropriate for denny who sort of
discovered this book at the time he did
in his teenage years but it reminds me
of those times when you're just sort of
drifting off in the summer and you're
looking through your eyelashes and
you're looking at the
distortions of the world and maybe
listening to i don't know a pink floyd
album at the time but it's kind of
hallucinatory in a really great way that
was one of the kind of key ingredients
it's there and i think pretty much all
of the dream visions how did you guys
was it always going to be
the ending of this movie was how early
on did everyone realize this is going to
be where we end the movie was it
something that was in this like this is
from the scripting phase all the way to
what people
see i mean like or was there a little
bit more debate that was that was that
was i hate to disappoint you but that
was the plan i mean it was um i mean
eric roth and
johnny spate and
denny it worked really hard and they
kind of i think eric roth kind of you
know he he cracked a lot you know he he
picked the lock if you like of the of
the film the structure um i know that
there was some debate because there's a
kind of natural place
uh later in the story where they could
have broken but it would have added
another hour of material so it would be
sort of um you know it would be a tough
watch but um no that was always the plan
that was you know it's um
it was built into what i i just cut what
they put in front of me which is i've
spoken to a number of editors um and a
lot of them have said to me there's
always one sequence in every movie that
they repeatedly go back to again and
again and again because they just always
want to tweak it because they're never
100
obviously i don't know if that happened
on this film but which is the sequence
if you had one that you kept going back
to
oh by far the gomjava was a scene that
we just kept tweaking i mean it was
really lovely that you know daddy at one
stage was up in montreal i'm down in los
angeles and he would do what he calls a
monkey cart
there's a some funny thing on youtube
which shows a chimpanzee in a film
cutting room sort of like
throwing bits of film all over the place
and that's what we refer to as the cuts
that denny would do so he'd take my cup
and then he'd put it in imovie or
something simple and he would do the
kind of the most beautifully crude um
version but it was actually like
sometimes when a cutter is really
advanced like that and specifically that
scene which has got
millions of cards in it it's like really
really fast cut sequence
that it was kind of shorthand he wanted
to actually play with it himself and so
he'd send me down his monkey cut i'd i'd
conform his monkey cut and then i'd say
oh that's great but what about this and
then we go backwards and forwards so
that one that one kept evolving right to
the last minute you know every little
sound effect comes in
alters how long you stay on something
you're constantly sort of nibbling away
and putting a couple of frames on and
bringing in more sounds because you know
part of this that scene is the voice
and uh that took a long while to to
figure out um whose idea was it was it
in the script or was it in the edit when
because what's interesting about the
movie is before the warner brothers logo
you have dreams or messages from the
deep with that sound and it's it's you
know it's very unusual to do this uh
how'd that come about
oh we yeah i mean at one point i
actually said to danny do you think we
need to ask permission to do this i mean
it's kind of it's going to freak out a
few projections i think not to start
with the logo
um
you know the idea came about because
how to start the film is like is you
know start the beginnings of
special places in the film and we wanted
to kind of sew this hostile voice of the
sardar car that you don't really need in
the store until much later
you have to kind of you know we
concentrated on establishing the fremen
and the harkonnens and spice
at the beginning and that's really quite
a lot to establish
to water that down by also
referring to the emperor's elite
battling army felt um wasteful you know
you don't need to encounter them until
an hour and a half later so but we
wanted to kind of start with this super
aggressive voice and actually it was
recorded not by
the dialogue team although they would
have loved to have done it it was
something that came from hands
um
he said at one point i've got this
amazing throat singer and his voice
hans is so amazing he would he would
just we get this kind of uh
he'd lob a call at us like a little
facetime video and you you're suddenly
joining him and a vocal um casting agent
and two artists who do uh vocal
specialties and and he gets me and denny
on the line to say what do you think of
this and then he says to the guy off you
go and the guy goes
and we go
we love it hands we love it so
but that that idea came from hands as
did many many wonderful sounds and
musical sort of semi-musical things
um but that idea and i think also it
actually belongs slightly to
uh
blade runners start in a kind of dream
you know with uh ryan gosling's
character kay asleep at the
controls of his spinner
um i don't know it's i like the idea of
films being a sort of hallucination i
will say one last thing
sorry for the long answer but
one thing that i particularly love about
working with denny's films is that they
do seem to work in this kind of old
brain way i can't i don't know what the
correct words are but there's sort of
some
you know with your limbic system or your
you know some basal
structure right they sort of lots of his
images resonate in that very dreamlike
way
not necessarily
um
you wouldn't notice them as planted but
i i think sometimes there's one image
that really sticks in my head from this
film which is of oscar isaac's putting
his hand on
on rebecca ferguson's neck there's a
little scene and it says so much about
the trust between them and about her
vulnerability at that time and her faith
in him
and yet it's you could have done a
20-page dialogue scene between them that
would never have conveyed all of that
quite so successfully
so i and i i think of films like sicario
where i think that was you know that
nape of the neck was
used then you know a shot of reggie
outside before an explosion goes off in
a tract house
he dwells on things and it's part of
editing to try and give that enough time
and space and to remind yourself of how
powerful and dreamlike some of those
images are one of the things that i
commend you on and you know you and
denis together is that
their
the movie
does
has to do so much with so many
characters and such little screen time
because there's so much of this story
and what i commend you guys on and you
just mentioned like that particular
scene with rebecca and oscar
is that it's these little moments where
you gain so much knowledge and you need
to pull that off in multiple times
through the movie you know whether it be
jason and you know timothy in their
relationship like the list goes on and
on and on but and i can spend a lot of
time on that but i want to um
one of the things i'm curious about is
it's kind of interesting though because
there's as an editor there's so many
things in the film that i if you're
trying to tighten up a film and it
always feels like you know we belong me
and denny and steve mcqueen we all
belong to that kind of like we don't
want to have any flab in the film so in
the edit you obviously start looking at
things and i remember so there's lots of
low-hanging food that
would have been easy to cut but i'm
really glad that we didn't you know it's
kind of little things like
for example there's a scene with the
gardener there's an amazing scene with
the gardener on arrakis and he explains
how he maintains
10 palm trees what it takes
and that they're of sacred importance
and if you didn't do that then you
wouldn't kind of really encounter
the people of the planet and and to a
degree the fremen culture which is
really important and you know paul's
whole the success of paul the trade is
is that he's curious about the world
that he goes into the fact that he looks
at a
little film book narrated by a fantastic
englishman by the way
who
who
is me and uh
i'm the i'm denny's go-to for the smooth
talking sound of british imperialism by
the way um but because he watches the
film book and he sees a little dance on
the sand you know it saves his life
later in his mother's life so um
i i kind of feel like it would have been
easy to cut those details you know if
you were just going for a wham-bam slam
kind of cut
but i think they're really absorbing it
it means when you see those palm trees
on fire later there's some emotion about
it you feel as though something really
sacred has been trampled uh a hundred
percent the other thing is
i've had this conversation with other
people when you have an hour and 45
minutes or two hours to tell your story
you have to rush through so much and the
longer running time allows you to have
these moments you know and it's one of
the reasons why
you know when you can make a three hour
movie why for example avengers end game
um you know you have a lot of moments
you normally can't have because you have
that extra hour to work with you know
you guys had a longer running time to
work with
i think there's an appetite you think
for kind of you know these
more kind of like a novel rather than a
novella you know it's it's a kind of you
know something where you settle down
you know we wanted to establish the
characters and for you to get to know
them before they're immersed in kind of
you know freakish amount of danger so um
it's it's sort of you know the pace we
take our time to set up the politics of
the place i mean if you were selling
something in brooklyn in 2021 you
wouldn't have to spend any time at all
you just cut to it and nobody has to
explain how cars work or computers work
but you know we're in 25 000 year 25 000
so quite a lot of you know it's quite a
lot to catch up yeah like i said um if
you want to show me the four-hour cut
anyway going on to my next i'm joking
i'm joking
um so one of the things i have to i'll
have to get busy cutting but yeah but
he's throwing that out there i want to
see it all um so with uh roger deakins
when he shot blade runner he shoots with
no coverage he in sicario he shoots or
what he told me is he shoots you know
one camera and i'm just curious
oh no there's but there is coverage i
mean there's a lot to cover
he just but he doesn't shoot multiple
cameras so i guess what i'm curious
about with this film is for example um
there uh how do you decide when you want
to use the close-up versus the wide shot
versus going wide shot close-up
mid-shot whatever you're going to do
like can you sort of talk about how that
all comes
this is this is the kind of job um and i
think sometimes you look at the coverage
of a scene coverage for people who don't
understand that word it means that you
know you don't just
film somebody saying the line and then
you film somebody saying the reaction
you will do the whole scene
and so you get multiple versions
of the scene because there'll be maybe
three four five takes for the actor and
the director to be happy with how a line
is delivered i'm talking about dialogue
scene but this also applies to action um
and also then you're also going to
probably shoot on different lens sizes
wider shots closer shots tracking shots
big close-ups and there's an intensity
to big close-ups that is a kind of you
know it's a special source so you don't
really
want to you know
fritter that away and thread away the
power of it it's very very important
to strategize when you're going to be in
those very close moments because for an
audience they're very intense
and
the wide shots can also be very intense
in a different way because
you get obviously the whole panorama of
things you get the whole world but
sometimes you can also emphasize a
character's loneliness or that kind of
you know discombobulation to use a kind
of awesome wells term
um
this film funnily enough i think is sort
of like deals mostly in the wide and the
very close it's kind of interesting
there's
you know not so much in the middle
so but you know when you look at a scene
as an editor i'm always kind of going
well when do i go to the close when do i
go when do i want to land on that most
emphatic moment the most powerful
use of a shot that i can use is probably
going to be the closest one when do i
when do i build up you know you build up
to it sometimes i start cutting the
scene at that point and work backwards
um
you know i know that i want to this is
the moment in the scene that's the most
important
point in the scene that's the key moment
how do we get to it and i work outwards
from that point uh the beginning and the
end of the film have some slow motion
shots um and i'm curious
how did you decide was that in the
script was how did you guys figure out
those those shots
the really simple answer is just decided
on onset and shot that way
i'm trying to think what there is
i could be wrong about the end it just
felt like i said
you're totally right about the beginning
that because the beginning is a scene of
charlie narrating a battle between the
fremen and the harkenans uh with a spice
harvester kind of obliterating a crowd
of
of uh
freeman and and obliterate yeah i think
a lot that was all shot
sort of you know uh i can't remember
third speed i think yeah obviously i'm
wrong about the end i just thought i saw
one but clearly i you know far more
about me you might be no you might be
right i think there was one tiny little
actually there's one really there is one
you're right there is one
tiny little glimpse and actually it's so
subtle i wonder if people will see it
but you know uh paul sees a vision of
charney very early in the films in the
first sequence and it's kind of backlit
shot with this incredible fringing of
the light that i talked about and i just
dropped the very same shot into a kind
of reality sequence which is with uh
with uh zendaya turning back towards him
and saying a a key line and i just put
that little moment in there it was kind
of a book ending thing so you're right
there is a book ending you know so
you're right it's at the beginning and
the end of the film you're more you know
you know the film better than i do my
friend steve you i don't i don't think
that's true but i may have seen it twice
and the second time i took notes and i i
you know um i thought i saw a
slow-motion thing at the end because it
was only the beginning and the end of
the movie that i noticed slow motion so
i thought that you know yeah now you're
you're absolutely right there's a little
bit of slow motion in quite a few of the
um dream visions for example when they
they move into a cave at one point and
they see this little desert mouse more
deep and that's that's slow motion as
well there's there's there are little
moments and there's a
that whole sequence that sort of memory
of a stabbing is and the signific
significance of a knife that's there's a
lot of slow motion
i love some of the establishing shots in
this movie uh where you have spaceships
where it's overlooking the city whatever
it may be the establishing shots are
great how do you know
where to cut how do you know
this is the exact moment and cut i mean
did you ever like did you guys have long
like do you ever have long you know what
i mean can you sort of talk about that
figuring out
well
the truth is you have to kind of figure
those things out in the cut and
because you know vfx it's huge cost to
make 10 seconds more i mean if you take
a shot for example there's an amazing
establishment one of my favorites is
where um
timothy timothy's character paul and
lady jessica rebecca ferguson they're
running up a dune they've escaped some
danger and they run up a dune at night
and they look out and they see the whole
of arakin
and it's it's on fire and there's like
uh it's just the harken and fire is
raining down on the city and that's
where
the man that they you know they
obviously love the most is is is in
great peril
and all of their family is in great
power so um but that moment you know you
had to cut the scene with an imagination
of what was going to be there and
you know i use every trick in the book
to do that normally sound helps me i
kind of
get stuck into sound really early as an
editor most people wait until they've
done um they finish their fine cut and
then start working on the sound i start
almost as soon as they've shot it so we
had fear green
uh come over to budapest and he would
develop sounds and it just helps be a
placeholder so you can say no i'm not
going to cut it tighter because you'll
need that time you really need to see it
and i'm kind of all about that and you
know i don't want things to kind of just
go past and not really to care about
them it's imbued with meaning what
they're looking at so i just wanted to
hold on to it and i'll use sound or
music or whatever i can
temporary vfx as a way of kind of
holding on to that space and and uh you
know ring fencing a certain amount of
time um
because i've already been talking to you
for a while i want to jump if you don't
mind real fast onto something else i
love arrival um just i love that film
and uh i'm just curious if you talk
about uh
obviously the ending of that film when
amy realizes
uh what's when it's all coming together
at the end and she's looking for the
chinese leader and all that stuff can
you sort of do you remember what was it
like actually putting that together in
the edit because that sequence is so
great and i'm just curious how tough was
it to actually put that one together
oh my goodness well
well it was and apart from anything else
there was a lot of stuff that didn't
exist
i mean the um the spaceships never left
it was it was a different ending you
know it was one of the things that we
had to kind of work on
you know we had to kind of create um
lots and lots of of uh newscasters for
example at one point and create kind of
like the world you know
the kind of great thor
of everybody coming online again having
been blacked out in in a state of war
but the kind of intercutting with
general shang well my my former first
sister mary we always talk about
shanging a cut it's kind of new verb for
us which is
to and there's a bit of shanging in dune
to be honest we shanked um
lato's death
is is heavily shamed but the idea was to
kind of intercut the two things and
it was originally one scene after the
other if you could imagine in the
shooting script and they shot all that
material but we'd like the idea that
amy's character doesn't know what to do
while she's doing it so she's going down
a corridor with a satellite phone but
she doesn't know at that point exactly
what she's going to say or to who it's
like takes a little there's a tension
in that she knows she has to do
something but she doesn't know what it
is yet she has to take a
literal leap of faith
i shouldn't say a literal leap of faith
should i she should just take a leap of
faith
i'm editing myself now steve it's a kind
of occupational hazard but anyway i'm
glad you point to it it's one of my
proudest moments in editing it's like it
it really evolved that scene and it
always felt like it was missing one last
pass and right at the end thanks to a
note from a producer
who said do you think i think it was in
paramount we sat around and talked about
it and they said they said do you think
that there's some kind of compression
that could be done in those scenes and
and me and danny kind of thought of into
cutting it and it took a while to do but
yeah i love it really particularly oh
that's fantastic um i want to also just
touch on real quick blade runner 2049 um
when you think back on the edit of that
movie what's like the first thing you
remember
i always kind of felt like the most
important thing was to kind of keep the
try and preserve some of the kind of
beauty
of it you know the kind of walk through
the desert in las vegas which is just
some of the most beautiful material i've
ever received in my life as an editor
and you know be so easy to kind of like
cut that to shreds and uh i'm glad i
hope we didn't i mean it's you know uh
it's become an iconic look
and i've noticed that look appear in all
manner of things since then like in
advertising and and even in real life to
be honest there were some sort of
news photographs of north california
last year that reminded me enormously of
that
but uh
no my feeling with blade runner is um
uh
it's a beautiful film it's kind of you
know it's
you learn something from every film that
you do and i i feel like um
you have to kind of stay
firm and you know and stay
ah sorry steve i've lost my trip that's
the magic of editing yeah i don't i
don't know where i was going i just
think you learn something from every
you learn something from every film you
do and it felt like blade runner for me
was kind of a great learning curve in
terms of the amount of the effects and
building sequences and ring fencing time
like we talked about earlier
and you know by the time we started june
i think we felt like a really well
rehearsed band
yeah i mean i al i think that blade
runner and a r like all the films that
denise has made especially with the
larger budgets and the larger vfx all
led to him making dune you know i don't
i don't know
i don't know if dune i think dunes
amazing and i don't know if dune would
be doing his version of dune without
blade runner you know without working
with all those shots and vfx and
everything he learned making that movie
i couldn't agree more and uh you know
it's it's
the importance as a filmmaker of going
step by step and
you know on
on sicario i think there were i there
were a few hundred shots vfx shots so
mostly to do with putting vehicles onto
the bridge and developing
the sequence that's on the bridge the
big shootout on the bridge you know
there was a lot of set extension to be
done
things like that and there was a little
bit of work to be done on aerial shots
for example and that kind of work but
um
that's nothing compared to a rival which
had you know uh substantial characters
made entirely i mean
i had a blank screen that was you know
and at one point i had somebody in a
kind of green costume
um which is you know holding a tennis
ball on a pole
which isn't really
you know is is kind of an awkward look
and then
blade runner you know
hundreds and hundreds of shots in june
probably of the same nature if not more
um i don't know each time it just the
scale is
it just goes up a step and it's each
film is very ambitious anyway
um
and i felt jim was enormously ambitious
particularly kind of that amount of
world to set up that many characters
it's a it's a daunting task and
hopefully we've carried it off i'm going
to ask you a question about blade runner
which you didn't answer on dune but i'm
going to try it on blade runner did you
guys have a much longer cut did you were
there a lot of deleted scenes in that
one
i got into so much trouble on blade
runner because i referred to the fact
that the first assembly
which every editor's first assembly is a
little long you know uh i mean for
example in blade runner there was this
amazing material they did which was
their kind of version of the voigt camp
test if you remember there's a sequence
where he's stuck in a little box and
he's been subjected to kind of an
onslaught of questions which was like a
brilliant idea that ryan and a colleague
of his came to set with that idea of
taking the pale fire perm and sort of
blasting him with questions about each
word almost each syllable and i had 10
minutes of that in the cut i it was like
you know you could literally go out and
make a cup of tea come back and it would
still be running now
that's typical for an assembly but it
doesn't mean that that was ever the
intention for the film it was just i had
it i put it all in and i made a
reference in an interview unfortunately
about the fact that we divided the film
in two because our bladders went up to
the task of seeing it in one
and suddenly there was release the denny
cart yeah and uh
that any cut was what we all saw that's
that's our cut
i've tried explaining to people and i
think we can talk about it right now
there's the assembly cut and then
there's the first director's cut you
know and the assembly cut
for people that don't realize it's
literally everything that was shot
never intention with no intention of
people seeing it
the first director's cut is when you
guys have been in the edit for like 12
weeks you have a cut that you're maybe
happy with and then it's about refining
that cut and and you know maybe with
some filmmakers maybe that director's
cut that first director's cut could be
watched but it's rare
i you know it's a particularly difficult
thing for us because there's only one
editor on these films that's me i mean
you know on the bigger films you would
normally get
two or three editors working and that
can really speed things along and the
other the director becomes a bit like
rick wakeman you know in a yes concert
where he's got two keyboards and he's
going from one room to another room you
know
so uh but in this case you know we feel
it works better for us just
just to be for me on my own nobody else
gets to come
and the advantage of that for me is that
i get to know everything and
i know the material like the back of my
hand so if you need a shot of something
you know like a
some sort of device sitting on a table
you remember you cut it out of another
sequence it's like all of the b unit has
been viewed by me all of the aerial
speed all the model shoots all the vfx
plates and sometimes like in blade
runner vfx plates ended up prominently
being displayed in the film there was
one shot which was of the sea wall which
was not storyboarded it was just a
beautiful vfx plate of salt going over
the edge of
a black drape and it just looks so
phenomenal we said it should be in the
film it's just so mesmerizing and
beautiful so you know just being
intimately acquainted with all the
material it's very advantageous as f for
me and denny is it
and he then he feels like he he can you
know
uh deal with one person who understands
the whole available options
um with um
you know the disadvantage of that is
that that 12 weeks of director's cut
it's actually close to 10 and sometimes
even less than that
if you're thinking that you've also got
to get like maybe 910 vfx shots ready so
in the case of blade runner all of those
shots of um
of uh hannah de armas and uh mckenzie
you know
the kind of blurring of what we used to
call the the threesome scene um you know
we wanted a really good
version that's close close enough to
what the finished product will look like
so that people really understand what
it's going to look like and why i'm
holding on a shot so long um you know in
the case of june as well you've got you
know we we did an amazing amount of work
on tempe effects to kind of give to give
an impression in that director's cut of
what the things can look like really
going to look like
just not guessing but it's like here's
the worm and it's moving that fast
so to try and do that in eight to ten
weeks is is start to be you know i
realize
you know it's it's
nearly impossible
but i think the thing is that denny
works with the great trust of his
producers if it weren't the case then it
would be very awkward indeed because
that director's cut is is great but if
we all died that day if a bomb dropped
on sony or warner or wherever we're
working i would be very sad if people
thought that was the finished film
because you know we need to test it and
we need to test it by showing it to
producers and then later showing it to
audiences and you know getting a sense
of what's working and what isn't working
so
the process is longer than that it's you
know it's you normally show the
producers after about eight to ten weeks
um but luckily thanks to the kind of
trust trusted position we've been in
with our studios we've had longer you
know sometimes up to 10 to 15 20 weeks
more to kind of
like keep working and keep inventing
keep referring it's it's also it's um it
also comes from denise track record and
the films he's made you know if you're a
first time second time filmmaker you you
know you're in a different boat
you know and also very essential to us
which we didn't have during the pandemic
because they just weren't doing it is
testing it you know audience tests we
did do one but it was limited and
limited by the number of people that
were in the allowed in the theater and
that to me has become always become part
of the ritual of filmmaking is that you
at some point you know you think that
you've created we're always thinking
about what the audience wants to know
next because you always want as an
editor to position the story
alongside your audience or just slightly
ahead if ever you're behind you're in
trouble real trouble
so you're constantly kind of trying to
second-guess what the audience is
thinking of what questions are in their
mind and how delivering the answer you
know
in arrival we teased the aliens for so
long you just want to test whether the
tension of that
you know whether just showing a little
bit of ankle early in the film is going
to be enough
it's a striptease
you know and uh you can sense it in
in a room with 300 people in it you can
absolutely smell it you can feel it and
um it's a kind of essential part of the
process you know to deliver something
that is going to be pleasing to an
audience so you mentioned with dune and
test screening so you guys were able to
test screen it
we did one test screening but uh it was
limited it was limited and in fact i've
just worked on another film which we had
to test through people's um
uh you know video cameras
which was a kind of zoom test with 200
people which is bizarre
i have to pause you there so you showed
the movie online
and then people reacted
on zoom
this is a different film sure but i did
i did i the film i did after june is a
film called the unforgivable and it's um
we showed the film to people so we
broadcast the film at the same time as
looking at their video cameras with
their permission
and you end up looking you know what
really happens of course some people
you know they're wrapped up in a blanket
they've got a cat on their knee and
they're eating popcorn
and they're kind of netflix and chill
kind of people some people would fall
asleep and then we'd sort of turn them
off
um
and other people you after a short while
i was very nervous about it i've never
done it before i don't think many people
have done it before but i was nervous
that it wouldn't give me that feeling of
being in
you know the dark with a group of people
where there is a kind of sort of
chemical influence you know it's like a
comedy if people laugh then other people
feel they have permission to laugh as
well
you know um and then you hope that on a
film like bharat i imagine it's kind of
you know people are going to the cinema
expecting to laugh so that kind of group
dynamic is very very important in in the
success of cinema but here we are
looking at individual people all dotted
around the east coast none of whom are
in the same room as anybody else
but the one benefit that i did find is
you would look at some people's faces
are very animated following a story and
they'll be going
you know and you would home in on those
people you go okay i want to look at
brenda for like 10 minutes and see what
this film is looking like on her face
and it was like a little voyeuristic i
have to say
very virustic but it's with their
written consent
um and there was no funny business you
know which i have heard has happened on
occasion
but uh you know it's really interesting
way of measuring an audience and seeing
where the film
where the interest dipped honestly in
that particular occasion there was like
a sense that okay we need to get a
wiggle on here people are kind of
restless for for a kind of resolution no
for sure i mean every filmmaker i've
ever spoken to talks about the
importance of showing
you know
their film to a crowd because and i'm
sure it happens with you and denise at
some point you've watched the footage a
thousand times and you lose track of
is this good
yeah and i think also
we're searching for i feel like you know
i came from such kind of art background
you know i mean i was originally a
composer you know i sort of studied
classical music then i became a sound
editor and i've always felt
to some degree a sort of impostor in the
cutting room you know i always felt like
i came in the wrong room and they seemed
to accept me and then you know that was
back in 1985
and you know now here we are in 2021 i'm
still doing it but i've only just
started to feel with june that i've
that skill set has become
you know
apparent and useful you know and it's
partly to do with kind of trying to find
a rhythm for all of this material
whether it's musical or whether it's
stephen henderson's eyebrow or whether
it's a sound effect bring it
all together but also to kind of like
try and
yearn for
successful storytelling and that's
really important there was a really
revelatory moment when we were working
with hands
am i allowed to swear on your program
you are useful
permission to swap absolutely
well there was one time where hans was
working on some tiny little kernel idea
some little
piece of dna he was trying to kind of
figure something out he was playing on
the keyboard
and after a little while i said you know
hans what are you looking for
right now what are you looking for
and he said i'm looking for something
with the efficiency of the word [ __ ]
and i totally get it you know it's like
[ __ ] is an international word
you know chinese people use the word
[ __ ]
nuns use the word [ __ ] when they have uh
strokes apparently it's very very common
for a nun
i don't know why how they did that
survey but i have read it online so it
was interesting
um
totally
but it's also you can use it in a
multitude of ways you can say i i
[ __ ] love you you know or you could
say i [ __ ] hate you and it's got
strength
great strength and recognizability and
in some sort of way i understood what he
was trying to do with it what he's
trying to do by building this tiny
little brick that brick
has got to be capable of being a temple
or a hovel it can be water or it could
be fire in the story it has to be
adaptable it has to be kind of like a
bit of stickle brick i don't know if you
have that over here in in in the uk we
you know kids play with sticklebreak i
put little things together and build
castles and that's what he's looking for
in some way i feel like that's also what
i've been looking for with denny and
something that really excites me is to
try and find something that's got that
um the satisfaction and the depth and
the subtlety and the intelligence not to
treat its audience like idiots but
to treat them with great respect and to
be in step with them but also serve them
something that's universal simple
recognizable and kind of human big-time
on that note uh considering i've you
know we've spoken for a little while of
time i'm gonna uh say thank you um
sincerely my pleasure and again i want
to say you guys did such an amazing job
with this job's a fun chat steve thank
you
you